[Music]
this is David currently the tech culture
today we're here with Adam Lallana for
the launch of the new Pumas unpacked
Adams going to show us how to receive
the past and play the bully to the
striker place for orange cones which
replicate the back for and in in front
the midfield for so in terms of the
practice Adam will be receiving in
between the midfield and the defense so
he then can play a four pass into the
striker so step one out I'm gonna
dribble towards you yeah okay
and then you're gonna make your move in
between those two cones okay so that
would be the left wing guard sending
midfield and then you're against the
back four okay and then as I arrive step
two I'll play the pass into you you
produce a turn and then step three will
be the final pass in behind grid it yes
that good nice I like that in terms of
the weight of pass it's important isn't
it to get that weight the strike had
always determines that you know you can
see your timing so he knows when I'm
gonna hit it and what I get a sense is
that you're not you're not playing it
too hard
so you're leaving it foot so we can
arrive and you're gonna strike it in
maybe take it in one because you know
you're gonna be close to the goal
the balls arriving into you and here
would you be checking your shoulder just
in case so if this defender comes on
this side so if I'm a defender posing
you if you if you a defender coming at
me familiar the ball was here I what I'd
do is I'd take it on the back foot and
come this way away from you so if you
were coming on that's probably what I'd
do or who you have your arm and turn I
like to protect but naturally for me I'd
take the risk and take it on my back
foot okay you probably risk it and
fouled there a bit more yeah it's still
in your favor if you get fouled yeah
[Music]
finish
[Music]
you're checking your shoulders in here
is that so you can see where the striker
is so by the time you open up you know
you know what time exactly and moving
they're thinking it's I'm checking my
shoulder so I know whether the striker
here yeah
I haven't yet made my mind up where the
ball was gonna go okay so I'll make my
mind up in that split second once I have
my touch off it off where he's running
to okay so it's all dependent on on the
movement of course yeah that decides
that hyper posture you know finish yes
[Music]
nice if we could have free top tips for
four players no plane in this position
what would you say for me it would be
you receive way you're gonna receive the
ball yeah checking over your shoulder
second it is easier touch sometimes it's
no touch just use the pace of the ball
and the third has to be has to be the
way to pass and that's obviously
dictated by the movement of the striker
so they're they're the three tips I just
wanted to say think again thank you
there you go guys hope you enjoyed it
and learn something from it
don't forget to Like comment and share
[Music]